[Музика]
привіт, мене звати Наталія Супе, і настав
час для нашого уроку англійської мови, тому я сподіваюся, що
ви здорові та щасливі, тому що
ми багато займалися спортом, і ми багато говорили про
їжу, і ми продовжуємо  сьогодні ми говоримо про
смачну їжу та здорову їжу, тому
на попередньому уроці попередні уроки
ви вже навчилися готувати
тірамісу домашнє тірамісу, і ми
переглянули багато продуктів, і ми помістили
їх у різні групи,
переглянувши форму однини та множини
іменників countable  іменники незліченні іменники
і як їх використовувати з деякими будь-якими багато
багато, а також описуємо деякі фотографії
портрети та натюрморти, використовуючи наші
знання, тому сьогодні ми продовжуємо говорити
про здорову їжу, а перед цим я
хотів би перевірити ваші домашні завдання.
щоб описати це зображення,
використовуючи назви продуктів і деякі і будь-які
і багато у ваших реченнях,
подивіться на мій варіант, це зображення
Джузеппе Арчібальда, о, і є
опис є деякі гра  pes
ти бачиш там виноград деякі однолітки так
є горошок на голові цього
чоловіка вишні всі губи
Олівія дивиться яблука яблука ягоди та цибуля
на цьому портреті насправді
тут багато продуктів, це не будь-яка
картопля я не знайшов  будь-які, це
не ананаси і не
лимони, так, і
на цій картинці багато квітів, добре, тому мені подобається
це, тому ви можете зробити свій портрет
з продуктом і описати його так, як
зазвичай у нас є невеликий  або швидкий тест
на початку, тож давайте вставимо будь-які N
і M в ці речення добре, тому
перше речення дай мені банан, будь ласка,
ви покладете банан так, тому що це
форма однини злічуваного іменника чи
є виноград на столі, це
питання  так, ми використовуємо будь-який у запитанні
чи є виноград на столі
наступне Я хотів би з'їсти, що трохи чіпсів так,
тому що це стверджувальне речення
далі нам потрібні яблуко та вишні для
торта яблуко в однині ми використовуємо яблуко
та трохи вишень  для  пиріг хороший чи
є масло в холодильнику, це
питання, що ми використовуємо у цьому
питанні так будь-який у нас немає молока залишилося
чесно як смачно мелака міяко залишилося
добре в заперечному реченні ми використовуємо те, що
будь-який так, у нас немає молока  все ж
номер сім
я голодний я візьму салат,
трохи продам його добре, це ствердне
речення, і це останнє, у нас є
полуниця, тому ми можемо приготувати десерт, у
нас є трохи полуниці, щоб ми могли
зробити десерт
відмінним, щоб ми знали  що домашня їжа
дає нам енергію для зростання енергії, щоб
грати в ігри, енергію для навчання та енергію для
підтримки нашого тіла, але це
питання, що ми повинні їсти та пити,
і скільки ми повинні їсти та пити, щоб
бути здоровими, щоб відповісти на ці питання
ця піраміда допоможе нам, це називається
піраміда харчування або піраміда здоров’я, і подивіться,
ми розкладаємо різні продукти на різних
полицях, як це працює, ви повинні
їсти багато їжі внизу
піраміди і лише трохи їжі
вгорі  піраміда
так добре  ore ми аналізуємо цю піраміду, давайте
пройдемося через деякий словниковий запас, який нам знадобиться
для цього, так що словниковий запас інгредієнти
інгредієнти інгредієнти або соціальні
певні інгредієнти поживні речовини поживні речовини
Pavini rejuven поживні речовини ви можете
побачити їх у будь-яких продуктах ви можете
побачити цю невелику таблицю з інформацією
про  поживні речовини поживні речовини факти так
білок білок abou об'ємний жир
волокна волокна їй дати алюміній
вуглеводи вуглеводи moogle Avadi
вітаміни та мінерали вітаміни і я
ви отримаєте хвилину мінерал кальцій це
дуже важливо мінерал кальцій і
калорії калорії так
калорії ви бачите скільки
калорій  почути жир вуглеводи
білок вітамін і так далі, щоб ви могли побачити
це будь-який продукт, який ви купуєте в
супермаркеті, ще трохи словникового запасу
добавки добавки Dornish, оскільки зазвичай
вони не дуже корисні для вашого здоров'я,
це хімічні добавки для покращення
смаку або кольору добавки шкідлива
їжа  некаріс туніська нездорова їжа фаст-
фуд з великою кількістю добавок  ves так
цільнозернові він знає, що немає V
це дуже корисно для вашого здоров'я до
речі хто зерна збалансована дієта збалансована
дієта збалансована ідея духовки,
тому нам потрібно мати всі інгредієнти всі
поживні речовини, щоб мати збалансоване харчування добре
час від часу частування іноді частування це
горілка чеснота Ваня  net-net
cool є тільки з Joss Odom serving
serving support так, скільки
порцій цих продуктів нам потрібно, щоб
їсти знежирені добре дайте мені нуль я мав
його besakih, містер з низьким вмістом жиру джерело
джерел джерела та щоденні продукти, які ми
маємо  вже знаю цей щоденник про щоденні
продукти моджі Мелоні продуктивний добре,
тож давайте подивимося на вершину цієї піраміди,
що ми маємо тут, у нас є шкідлива
їжа або фаст-фуд, цей продукт
містить багато цукру, солі та жиру
, тому вони не є хорошими  для свого
здоров'я ви можете їсти їх принагідно
не щодня максимум один або два рази і
тиждень двічі devadasi на тиждень тестуючи,
що це за продукти чіпси газовані
напої шоколад або солодощі сам цукор
і фас  t їжа швидкого харчування, тому пам'ятайте,
що не їжте їх щодня
наступні жири, спреди та олія, їх
не так багато, але є оливкова
олія або соняшникова олія, вершкове масло, там
багато жиру і вітамінів, оливкова
олія корисніша за  соняшникова олія
добре, тож наступна полиця – м’ясо
птиця піца птиця риба яйця
боби та горіхи
ці продукти насичені білками
та жирами білків і Tet bilqis jury, тому
порада уникайте солоних та солодких горіхів, сіль
та цукор не так корисні для вашого здоров’я
та  намагайтеся вибирати продукти з низьким вмістом жиру продукти з
низьким вмістом жиру порт порцій кажуть
порції двічі на день 2 порції на день
це нормально, наступна одна молочний йогурт і сир
молочні продукти молочні продукти дуже
важливі для нашого здоров’я, тому
ми повинні їсти їх три  раз на
день так,
що це за продукти молочний сир
йогурт і ці продукти
насичені жиром, вітаміном кальцію і білком
кальцій дуже важливий для наших кісток
і зубів
, тому ми повинні їх їсти,
але  порада торгового центру для вас, вибирайте молочні
продукти з низьким вмістом жиру з низьким вмістом жиру, тому що занадто багато жиру,
це не добре, три порції на день, ми
повинні їх їсти добре наступна полиця
ці продукти як хліб рис картопля
макарони паста піца крупи вони
повні вуглеводів вуглеводи вони
дуже корисний, дуже корисний для нашого здоров'я, але
собачий хліб з дрібними кінчиками і коричневий рис є
чудовим джерелом цільного зерна,
вони більш здорові, ніж інші
види хліба, тому 3 і 5 або 3 5 порцій на
день корисні для нашого здоров'я  Гаразд
, і останній і найбільший,
але найважливіший - це полиця
з овочевим салатом і фруктами, ви бачите,
що всі ці продукти насичені
мінералами і вітамінами, вони дуже
важливі для нас, тому ми повинні
з'їсти їх п'ять  сім порцій на день п'ять
сім сонячних слуг на день і зверніть
увагу, фрукти та
овочі яскравішого кольору мають більше вітамінів,
ви побачите, наскільки вони яскраві, і подивіться
ще раз на нашу піраміду, і давайте зробити трохи
макіяжу  p кілька речень про те, скільки
слуг, скільки слуг
ми повинні наливати чай в день, добре, подивіться на
піраміду і складіть речення,
наприклад, якщо бажаємо, якщо ми подивимося на цю
полицю, речення буде таким:
ми повинні їсти пиріг
слуги з фруктів і овочів  день,
тому зробіть свої варіанти хорошими, а наступне завдання
давайте попрацюємо з невеликим текстом, який нам потрібно
заповнити, щоб завершити текст цими
словами, давайте розглянемо
слова добавки, які
ви знаєте, ці добавки доумекі прямі
продукти здорова їжа домашні
інгредієнти шкідлива їжа готова  -made and
sugar ok текст називається добре їжте та
будьте здорові.
OK Я прочитав його для вас, а ви спробуйте
поставити слова в пропуски, уважно подивіться
на продукти супермаркету, прочитайте їх, прочитайте
інгредієнти так і переконайтеся, що
їх не багато  не багато добавок
у речах, які ви купуєте, їжа часто містить
багато солі, а в якій
їжі багато солі та цукру
так,
готові
продукти часто містять багато солі та  ugar
і ви пам'ятаєте, що багато солі і
цукру не є корисними для вашого здоров'я,
намагайтеся не їсти занадто багато, яку
їжу так шкідливу їжу, це нормально
час від часу, але не кожен день намагайтеся
включати ммм у свій раціон, які
продукти включати здорову їжу  у вашому раціоні
натуральні продукти, такі як свіжі фрукти та
овочі, корисні для здоров’я, нам потрібні міцні
кістки та зуби, тому їжте багато
яких продуктів так
прямі продукти, такі як сир та йогурт,
вони дуже корисні для наших кісток та
зубів, ви також можете навчитися готувати
домашню їжу  є свіжим і корисним для вас,
тому ми можемо побачити, що домашня їжа
здоровіша, ніж готова, добре, і
останнє завдання на сьогодні - давайте заповнимо
цю тарілку, вони називають її їсти добре блюдо
з продуктами, про які ми вже
дізналися, щоб ви бачили  що ця
тарілка поділена на кілька частин
кілька частин так що ви думаєте, що
ми маємо помістити в цю частину що
ми повинні помістити в цю частину
що ваші нещасні
зелені найбільша добре ваша ва  ріант так
фрукти та овочі які
фрукти та овочі ми повинні сюди покласти
добре давайте покладемо сюди
лимон яблука ягоди всі види
ягід так банани та жир є
все дуже яскраве та важливе для
нашого здоров'я фрукти та овочі наступний
наступний цей жовтий  один, що ви
думаєте, що ми кладемо в цю частину,
що більше також дуже важливо для нашого
здоров'я що це зараз добре так
хліб рис макаронні вироби каші все, що ми
йдемо в цьому друга найбільша частина
хліб добре хліб на всіх продуктах
який також виготовлений із зерен зерна там
немає далі що ми маємо помістити в цю синю
частину що ви думаєте так щоденник продукт
стиль продукти всі продукти ми, які
є їжа з білком так і
найважливіше тут кальцій, тому нам
потрібно мати  багато з них це
третя велика частина цієї тарілки, а як щодо
цього рожевого один рожевий один добре
м'ясо риба та яйця так, тому що
є багато
білка, у цьому продукті багато білка, який ми
потреба для нашого здоров'я
так і остання остання
найменша - так шкідлива їжа ми не
маємо ми не повинні їсти таку їжу багато,
тому що ця
їжа повна солі, цукру та інших
добавок і тому не  не їжте їх
багато добре, тому це тарілка їжте добре
тарілка, щоб мати збалансоване харчування, щоб мати
збалансоване харчування, щоб бути здоровим, і на
цьому наш урок закінчився, і я хотів
би дати вам домашнє завдання, яке ви повинні
завершити речення цим  слово
і друге завдання, ви повинні зробити так, щоб ваша
тарілка добре їла, намалюйте свою тарілку і вкажіть
, скільки продуктів, скільки
продуктів ви їсте в день, і проаналізуйте, чи це
добре, чи
добре їсть тарілку, чи, можливо, їсть погано,
тож це буде  ваш домашній тест, і
тепер наш урок закінчився, будьте
здорові та щасливі, і до побачення
[Музика].